lutter contre les féminicides contre les
violences conjugales stopper l'horreur
voilà l'objectif de gérald darmanin en
2020 cent de femmes ont perdu la vie
sous les coups de leur conjoint ou ex
conjoint
un chiffre certes en baisse mais qui ne
signifie pas pour autant une baisse des
violences intrafamiliales
bien au contraire le nombre
d'interventions de la police et de la
gendarmerie pour violences
intrafamiliales reste très élevé plus de
400 milles soit 45 interventions par
heure il ne se passe pas une journée
sans que le gie et gêne ou le raid a
libéré une femme ou des enfants prise en
otage les violences intrafamiliales sont
en train de devenir le premier motif
d'intervention des policiers et
gendarmes
le constat est édifiant et justement
rien n'a été fait pour prendre la mesure
de ces demandes gérald darmanin serait
donc désormais un traitement prioritaire
des plaintes pour violences conjugales
un officier spécialisé dans ces
violences dans chaque commissariat et
chaque brigade de gendarmerie
l'objectif est de proscrire les mains
courant définitivement tout cela existe
déjà depuis un an l'an dernier à cette
date 57 femmes avaient été assassinées
par leur conjoint ou ex conjoint le
ministre de l'intérieur se satisfait de
cette baisse
il oublie de préciser que nous sommes
cette année à 70 féminicide il faudra
plus qu'une interview du ministre de
l'intérieur qui annonce des mesures déjà
existantes pour changer la donne nous
avons besoin de moyens supplémentaires
en effet un mois après la féministe et
de mérignac ou chahinez 31 ans mère de
trois enfants était assassinée par son
mari ces dispositions ont été prises
mais elles ne correspondent pas aux
attentes des associations féministes
pour plusieurs raisons tout d'abord
soulevez-vous fennesz avait déjà porté
plainte contre son ex mari le 15 mars
dernier et la manière dont cette plainte
a été prise
interroge car le policier qui avait
enregistré cette plainte avait lui-même
été condamné en février à huit mois de
prison avec sursis pour des violences
commises sur sa femme
il était à ce moment-là on attend de
passer devant le conseil de discipline
la question est de savoir pourquoi
avait-il encore le droit d'exercer
qui plus est le rapport envoyé à ce
moment là par courriel au parquet
comportait de nombreux manquements
c'est en effet inacceptable en février
il a averti sa hiérarchie de sa
condamnation à huit mois avec sursis
même si la justice a jugé qu'il pouvait
continuer d'exercer sa profession sa
hiérarchie n'aurait pas dû le laisser en
contact avec le public ce qui renforce
mon courroux c'est que ces informations
étaient cachés inspection que nous avons
commandé
j'ai donc demandé à vis gipn si certains
ont cherché sciemment à les dissimuler
une circonstance inacceptables comme le
dit et le ministre de l'intérieur le
rapport de la police des polices lui est
attendue d'ici à six semaines
trop long pour de nombreuses
associations élus qui ont décidé de
réagir à travers une pétition lancée par
le collectif abandon de famille
tolérance zéro est l'intitulé est clair
faire l'inventaire de ses forces de
l'ordre agresseurs de femmes et enfants
cette pétition témoigne un retard
conséquent de la justice française
concernant les féminicides une prise de
conscience qui est nécessaire avant tout
sur le plan juridique pour éviter de
nouvelles atrocités des formations
travail des magistrats de travail mais
on a beaucoup trop soir entre elles
notamment dois vous dire qu'on n'a
toujours pas de chronique sont
spécialisés ce qu'il faut là à ce moment
c'est des policiers spécialisés sur ces
questions les procureurs spécialisés sur
ces questions des juges spécialisés sur
la question des violences conjugales
magie et câlins qui à villalbe à pitre à
la question est légitime et c'est
essentiellement sur sac le ministre de
l'intérieur va devoir travailler une
solution mettre plus de moyens dans ces
formations et dans l'encadrement des
forces de l'ordre un milliard d'euros
seraient nécessaires selon l'association
osez le féminisme
reste à savoir si le gouvernement sera
réceptif à cette proposition